first of all I want to put on record my
deepest thoughts and sympathies for the
family of Nicola bully it must be a
horrendous experience that they are
going through right now we need to let
the police carry out and conclude their
investigation I did have concerns
earlier in the week about some of the
elements really relating to the release
of personal information of Nicola bully
into the public domain I raise those
concerns with the chief Constable I
wasn't wholly satisfied I have to say
with some of the responses I got but it
is a matter for the police themselves
there are some investigations ongoing
looking into how the investigation has
been handled and we must let that carry
out its own process but